foreign
comes from Dan in Massachusetts I'm
finishing up my degree in accounting
with absolutely zero dollars in debt and
can get my CPA license to work at a big
company soon however I'm also
considering law school which would cost
around three hundred thousand dollars
not including interest the starting
salary for some lawyers and can be 210
000 in my city however for accountants
at Big firms that salary can take around
five to six years to get while law
school would only be about three years
to complete is it financially worth the
trade-off to go into debt if it will
increase my income faster or should I
stay with my accounting degree and
increase my salary at a slower pace
well you know these kind of questions
are always very nuanced and very
difficult to answer you know in a back
in without a van on the fourth I don't
have Dan on the phone so I'll dive into
um the considering Law School
why are you considering law school are
you considering law school because of
the sheer Financial difference that you
see here it tends to the tone of his uh
question George leads me to believe that
he's thinking of law school primarily
for money reasons and I would always
caution against that I'd want to know
why did you choose to go into accounting
you know do you love the work does the
work create results that matter to you
um and and I got to tell you um
the 300 000 George I'm passionate about
this
you should never pursue a law degree
when you'd have to go into debt three
hundred thousand dollars to that school
here's why uh quick context several
years ago I had the opportunity to
interview a lawyer on the Ken Coleman
show based in Houston went to Vanderbilt
very high-end School here in Nashville
and he realized after the fact
that he could have kept taking the LSAT
got his GPA and his LSAT score to a
certain point where he could have gotten
free rides two smaller lesser known less
prestigious law schools okay but you
know you you don't think that and
largely you don't know that and so in
this situation a law degree is a law
degree unless you get it out of a
Frosted Flakes box right yeah and so I I
just would not be thinking about this
kind of money I would be trying to get a
free ride to a smaller law school if
giant caps if law is what you really
want to pursue but to pursue a law
degree because you go well I can make a
little bit more money faster than I
could as an accountant an accountant has
just as much opportunity to move up into
a c-suite opportunity later on so I I'd
want to know those things before I
decide oh absolutely and his his
verbiage here the starting salary for
some lawyers can be two hundred ten
thousand sure I've got friends who are
low lawyers and they went into deeply in
debt for their degrees and they're
making 65k doing immigration law or some
types that aren't at these big firms so
this idea that you're just going to have
a high six-figure salary as soon as you
leave Law School is also a farce so
don't believe that lie
and if it means hey I'm going to have
this kind of salary in five years
that's great if you love accounting
stick with accounting never get a degree
just for the paycheck that see the
paycheck wears off George well and how
many lawyers do we have out there that
are resenting ever having gone to law
school that didn't make it who still
have their student loans to pay off yeah
or who are doing it going I want to jump
into a different field this is not what
I thought it was going to be I'm burnt
out I'm doing 80 hour weeks at firms
that don't care about me so this all
points to the issue of higher education
the student loan crisis which we delved
into with our documentary borrowed
future